so
a warm welcome to all of the gamers
tuning in from around the world
and a big thank you to all of our
partners and resellers who support
selling the amd radeon brand
watching this today i'm excited to be
here with you and share the details of a
brand new radeon graphics gpu
we are so happy that so many of you
share our passion for gaming
this passion has been going on strong
for over 30 years
throughout these years we have been
standing by our core values of
innovation and open standards bringing
you new gaming products and technologies
all while making them widely accessible
at its core the video game industry has
been about innovation
new technologies new games and new
experiences are expected every year
so it should be no surprise to anyone
that with the introduction of new
processors
graphics cards and gaming consoles 2020
was the biggest year ever for the gaming
industry
there were 3.1 billion gamers last year
which is almost 40 percent of the
world's population
powering a 174 billion dollar gaming
industry
there is no doubt that pc console and
mobile gaming is one of the largest
entertainment industries
in the world leading up to today amd has
accelerated our investment
in gaming features to produce new
technologies that dramatically improve
your game play
in the short time since we introduced
our first generation amd rdna
architecture in the summer of 2019
we pioneered responsivity features known
as radeon anti-lag
which enables lower input latency for
competitive gaming
and radeon boost which encompasses the
input latency reduction of anti-lag
while also providing performance
increases anti-lag was available on all
dx9 and dx11 games
and boost was available on 8 popular
games by the end of 2019
we have been committed to developing
these features and have some exciting
enhancements
to talk to you about later on in 2020
we pioneered amd smart access memory
technology
we were the first company to seek out
and popularize the standard resizable
bar technology
and bring that performance benefit to pc
gamers around the world
we enabled additional performance in
many games for our ryzen 5000 series
desktop processors
and radeon rx 6000 series graphics cards
a lot of you have been asking us about
support on previous generation cpus
with amd smart access memory so today
we are announcing that in addition to
the ryzen 5000 series processors we will
be enabling
ryzen 3000 series processors to deliver
the same great performance improvements
of amd smart access memory technology
when paired with an amd radeon rx 6000
series graphics card
we love coming up with features like
this for gamers and we have a lot more
in store
last year we launched our radeon rx 6800
series and rx 6900 xt
graphics cards featuring the efficient
and feature-packed amd rdna 2
architecture
with amd rd and a2 we were able to hit
up to 65 percent
more performance per watt than the
previous amd rdna architecture
plus we built in all the latest
technologies and features
that gamers will use for years to come
the radeon rx 6900 xt rx 6800
xt and rx 6800 graphics cards are truly
next generation gpus built to deliver
full immersion in your latest games
allowing for maximum settings while
playing at 4k resolutions
today our amd rdna2 family of gpus is
growing
towards the end of 2020 we introduced
big navi which was affectionately named
by amd fans around the world
and now we are bringing the next step
down in our product stack to reach even
more gamers
we are proud to announce our latest amd
rdna2 gpu chip
the radeon rx 6700 xt designed
specifically to accelerate your gaming
experience at 1440p resolution
and of course at max settings over 95
of gamers in the world play on displays
that have 1440p resolution or below
and not surprisingly the 1440p
resolution is the fastest growing
monitor segment
that gamers are upgrading to with a 44
growth in sales year over year which is
why we built the rx 6700 xt to perform
extremely well
at this resolution perhaps more exciting
is that gamers are catching on to the
importance of having a high refresh rate
capable monitor
so that your gpu and monitor can take
advantage of every fast frame in highly
competitive games
the industry experienced over 98 percent
display shipment growth of 1440p
greater than 100 hertz refresh rate
monitors year over year
which is exactly why we built the rx
6700 xt
thermals and sound matter so we've
invested heavily in
every exquisite detail for maximum
results
the rx 6700 xt thermals are built to
handle large workloads cooling your gpu
while providing horsepower when you need
it
and is also whisper quiet when you don't
each rx 6700 xt made by amd
features a custom dual axial fan design
meant to deliver up to 50 percent
less perceived noise versus previous
blower designs
these cards feature the same 0 rpm fan
mode as the other rx 6000 series cards
to ensure the best operations in low
usage mods
underneath the cover we've optimized the
design around three heat pipes with fins
held securely in place with a single die
cast aluminum frame
the cards feature 11 phases for high
efficiency high performance at very high
clock speeds
to further ensure high performance each
card features two layers of two ounce
copper
within each tin layer pcb we use a high
performing
reliable phase change thermal interface
material for effective heat dissipation
and heat flow into the heat pipes these
boards feature 12 gigabytes of high
performance gddr6
support the latest pcie 4.0 motherboards
and standard edge based power connectors
last but not least the rx 6700 xt
supports displayport
1.4 and hdmi 2.1 for the latest high
refresh rate displays in the market
now that you've seen what's under the
hood let's take a look at performance
we know most of you today may still be
using graphics cards from three or four
years ago in your pcs
and are starting to see some challenging
performance in the latest games
in games like assassin's creed valhalla
borderlands 3
call of duty cyberpunk 2077 and even
dirt 5
cards like the nvidia gtx 1070 ti
struggle to get good performance at
1440p
with maximum settings even if you have a
more recent rtx 2080 super
you will find newer games challenging on
your gpu for playability
the radeon rx 6700 xt is a great upgrade
that will allow you to deliver high
frame rates at 1440p
with everything turned on in these
modern titles
let's also talk about future readiness
one of the reasons the rx 6700
xt is so great with modern titles is
because we've equipped the rx 6700xt
with 12 gigabytes of gddr6
to handle increasing texture loads and
greater visual demands that modern games
at higher resolutions
and max settings throughout your desktop
pc
games such as call of duty black ops
cold war dx12
ultra with high texture packs consume
approximately 11.1 gigabytes
dirt 5 and dx12 ultra high settings
consumes
9.5 gigabytes horizon zero dawn dx12
ultimate settings can easily use 10.4
gigabytes
and my favorite red dead redemption 2
vulcan
ultra 9.4 gigabytes with the amd radeon
rx 6700 xt
you can expect this new gpu to handle
today's demanding
aaa titles and those that will be
launched in the coming months
we've just looked at how the rx 6700xt
performs
relative to previous generation gpus now
let's see how it performs relative to
modern competition
as you can see in games like assassin's
creed valhalla
borderlands 3 hitman and many more the
radiant rx 6700 xt competes
exceptionally well for those of you who
want to try out ray tracing the radeon
rx 6700 xt
features 40 ray accelerators for full
directx ray tracing support
but ray tracing is just one part of our
visual initiative
and we are optimizing games alongside
other techniques in our amd fidelity fx
feature set
to allow for a complete high frame rate
experience
games like dirt 5
godfall world of warcraft shadowlands
and the rift breaker feature the latest
directx 12 ultimate techniques and
amd fidelity fx to bring both high
performance and enhanced immersion to
more games
amd fidelity fx is yet another example
of the power of open standards and
amd initiatives to improve the
experience of pc gaming for more gamers
the fidelity fx feature set includes a
variety of techniques that sharpen
denoise and add detail shadows and many
more visual enhancements to make your
games look better
it's a big reason why amd fidelity fx
with just two years of development
is already in over 40 games and counting
the next exciting title featuring both
ray tracing
and amd fidelity fx will be from our
partners at capcom
resident evil village the eighth major
entry in the resident evil series
demonstrates what is possible with ultra
realistic graphics
powered by the re engine and the latest
generation radeon rx 6000 series
graphics cards
the next generation of visuals for both
ray tracing and amd fidelity fx
really add to the atmosphere and
experience these games are known for
be sure to check out resident evil
village may 7 2021
as important as realistic visuals are we
know that competitive gamers who are
playing esports titles today
desire the best responsiveness latency
and smooth frame rate technologies
radeon anti-lag enables lower input
latency and radeon boost encompasses the
input latency reduction of anti-lag
while also providing performance
increases in select games
and these features along with amd
freesync technology can reduce lag
make games more responsive and enable
tear-free gaming
what's new with radeon anti-lag today is
that we've now added support for directx
12 which means anti-lag is available on
virtually
almost all popular games radeon boost is
now enhanced with the addition of
variable rate shading support
and an expanded list of supported games
that can take advantage of this feature
your goal in any competitive games is to
win
let's take a look at radeon boost in
action when you're in an intense matchup
you want to quickly target
and shoot the enemy before they notice
you enabling radeon boost will certainly
enhance
your ability to win in a 1v1 scenario we
achieve this by varying the shading rate
happening on screen
during that character movement without
noticeable image degradation
in the example here we have the radeon
rx 6700 xt
running fortnite averaging around 120
frames per second without boost enabled
by enabling radeon boost gamers can get
up to 150 frames per second or more
when your in-game character spins to
target and shoots at an opponent
instantly providing an increased
performance at the most critical time
another important piece of the ultimate
gaming experience is having a monitor
that matches the output of your graphics
card
amd freesync premium and freesync
premium pro monitors
are the perfect pairings for radeon rx
6700xt
enabling low latency high competitive
refresh rates
and smooth gaming last year alone we
certified nearly 250
premium and premium pro displays with
the high refresh rate freesync premium
displays
you will want a graphics card that can
deliver high frame rates
and the rx 6700 xt delivers that easily
in your favorite competitive games the
rx 6700 xt can easily drive the latest
165hz
1440p displays even if you've maxed out
all the visual settings
having the best hardware adds a
competitive advantage and by combining
the latest ryzen processors and radeon
graphics cards you unlock the full
performance potential of your rig
thanks to amd smart access memory radeon
anti-lag
and of course amd freesync technologies
we're so excited to announce that our
latest esports partner
taking advantage of this powerful
hardware combination is the mercedes amg
patronus esports team
their esports team has recently switched
their gaming rigs to an all amd platform
providing a highly optimized competitive
gaming experience
with the same kind of championship level
performance as seen on the grid
but now in virtual formula one amd ryzen
processors and radeon graphics together
provide high octane performance
responsibility for those hairpin turns
and the smoothest driving experience
during every second of gameplay
the combination of fast reaction times
with low latency is the difference
between winning
or finishing outside the podium we're
looking forward to seeing the team
achieve
great results in this year's upcoming
competitive season whether you're
playing the latest demanding games
at the top of the leaderboard and
carrying your team or enjoying the
latest in immersive visuals
the radeon rx 6700 xt is a fantastic
graphics card for you
now let's talk about availability
the amd radeon rx 6700 xt will be
available on march 18th
with an scp at 479 on amd.com
demand for gpus is at an all-time high
right now and in order to maximize
availability at launch
we are launching both made by amd
reference designs for sale on amd.com
and our aib partner designs at retailers
and retailers
across the globe on day one you'll be
able to purchase the radeon
rx 6700 xt at your favorite website
starting march 18th lastly for those who
do not want to build a pc for themselves
the rx 6700 xt is also available with
the ryzen 5000 series processor
from 40 plus system build partners
including the latest
hp omen pc launching later this month
we are excited to have the radeon rx
6700 xt
join the 6000 series family with next
generation technology advancements
future ready memory capability and
competitive software features
while 2021 is just getting started so
are we
expect even more rdna2 announcements
soon from us
to expand our family even further until
next time everyone
stay safe and have fun gaming
you